artificial intelligence is
revolutionizing nearly every aspect of
our society recent Technologies like
neural networks deep Learning Foundation
models have led to powerful new AI
capabilities and applications but how do
you stay on top of a field where things
are changing so fast especially when you
already have a day job I'm Chris Manning
professor of computer science
Linguistics and director of the Stanford
artificial intelligence lab here in the
heart of silicon Valley even if you're
not a student in my classroom here at
Stanford there's a way for you to learn
about the latest research and practical
applications of AI directly from our
world-class faculty in our artificial
intelligence professional program at
Stanford online you'll get the same
rigorous Cutting Edge content we teach
in our graduate courses here at Stanford
in each 10- we online course you'll have
the opportunity to meet your peers from
organizations around the world to to
test your knowhow in challenging
practical assignments and to get support
and feedback from course facilitators
people who have taken the graduate
courses themselves and are now working
in Industry our courses cover many of
the major branches of AI machine
learning reinforcement learning mural
networks natural language processing and
understanding Stanford's world-renowned
faculty are research Trailblazers whove
profoundly shaped the subjects that they
teach
they're not just instructors they're The
Architects of AI Stanford has long been
at the Forefront of AI in fact the term
artificial intelligence was coined by
former Stanford computer science
professor John McCarthy who organized a
Summer Conference at Dartmouth in the
1950s John was the founder of the
Stanford artificial intelligence lab
that I'm honored to lead today so
whether you're an aspiring AI
professional or an established expert
looking to take your skills to the next
level the Stanford AI professional
program will challenge Inspire and
Empower you to unlock the tremendous
potential of AI and to become a leader
in the field come join us at Stanford
online